KYLE KEANE: So my rant--
not rant.
I keep using the
word rant today.
My pitch about that is that
some people view creativity
as everything they do
has to be totally unique
and they need to think
of it all on their own.
Otherwise, it's not that
cool and they shouldn't
be proud of what they did.
And a lot of creativity
happens by taking something
that somebody else has done,
following what they've done,
and then making a
small adjustment,
and then making another
small adjustment.
And then suddenly,
you have something
that does something
different, that
is unique, that
you made yourself.
And that is creative.
There's nothing wrong with
taking something, learning
how somebody else did
it, modifying it to suit
your needs.
That is part of the
creative process.
And a lot of times,
it's the biggest part
of the creative process for a
lot of different disciplines.
It's like science
is built on that.
You have to do a bunch
of stuff, and then
make a small modification,
because that's
what you're able to do.
And then you publish that and
somebody else does everything,
does what you did,
and then makes
another small modification.
We have a tendency
to hold up heroes,
like Tesla or Einstein
or great inventors, who
did these amazing things,
despite no one else
ever having had that thought.
And that's just never the case.
There's always a
history of scientists
or a history of
artists or history
of people who laid a foundation
that these people were trained
and learned how to do
what other people had done
and then they make
small modifications.
So these first two
days are that process.
We have taken the
Roll-a-Ball ball tutorial
and we've just followed along
and we've talked to our friends
about it.
And we asked each other
to do small modifications,
like add new balls.
What does that mean?
Can you please help
me do this thing?
And today, we're
going to take it
and we're going to modify it.
And somebody did a really
cool thing-- or started to--
yesterday.
So they tried to take the
ball and turn it into an egg.
And I think that's
the perfect example
of taking something that's
built and being like, what can I
do to tweak this to make it
kind of fun and different?
And so turning the ball
into an egg is a great one.
When I first did
this, I took the ball
and I turned it into 25 small
balls that were all talking
to each other via gravity.
So instead of just having one
ball roll around the rink,
I had 25 small balls that were
all attracted to each other
by gravity, and so
they would roll around
and when they would hit the wall
they would go [SOUND EFFECT],,
and they would
kind of spread out
and then come back
together and clump up,
because they wanted
to be near each other.
So that's some small
modification of Roll-a-Ball.
And the reason you do
small modifications
is to make sure
that you understand
all the fundamental pieces of
what's happening, because unity
is this system that has objects
and has a file hierarchy
and that has the
methods that you put on
to things, like scripts
that you attach to objects,
and then you can apply coloring
and textures to the objects.
And there's all these
parts moving around.
And by making small
modifications,
you actually understand
if you understand.
If you can't modify
something, then there's
some fundamental
internal representation
of what's happening that needs
to be worked out a little bit
more, probably by
talking to some friends
while you're sitting
inside of a room like this.
This is a great place to learn.
So that's my pitch as to why we
have structured the first two
days in this way.
And then tomorrow,
you'll be kind of left
to come up with your own
idea and try to do a two day,
I've come up with
my own idea and I've
tried to get some people to work
on it with me type of thing.
And we'll do a small version of
that type of creativity, which
is I'm drawing inspiration
not from a tutorial,
but from out in
the world, and I'm
trying to combine
it with the stuff
that I learned
from the tutorial.
So there's this whole--
I kind of sat and thought about
how to structure this thing,
and I want to share that.
Because I believe kind
of knowing an approach
to education often
empowers people
to use it more effectively.